UP AGAINST THE THIRD BEST GOAL
PIECE THROUGH TRAFAF
GONE BY IN A SCORES ING IN.
JOHANSSON, AROUND THE RYTHING I
OVECHKIN IS ABLE TO STAY WITHTH
PERFECTLY EXECUTED!
ANOTHER WONDERFUL PLAY PUCK.
HE SAW OSHIE ON THE BACK DOOR
BEFORE THAT GOT TO HIM.
YOU COULD SEE OSHIE THE
BOARD!
TERRIFIC ANSWER INSTEAD HITS HI
PLAYER, LARS ELLER, AND A GOOD
FISHING, AND FEHERVARY MAKES
SC
LARS ELLER!
TIC-TAC-TOE HOCKEY FOR THE
FLYERS UP FRONT.
THREE ON TWTWEARY, WHO
FOUND HIMSELF WIDE OPEN WITH
PLENTY OF TEAM  CHASES.
YOU HAVE TWO DEFENSEMEN UP BY
THE BLUE LINE.
NOBODY COVERING THTHBACK
OF THE NET, AND WASHINGTON
CONTINUES TO POUR IT ESN'T EVEN
IT.
YOU HAVE HAGG IN FRONT OF YOU.
BREAKDOWN T HERE.
WHEN HE DOES THAT, HE DOESN'T
HAVE SO A SAVE MADE BY JONES, T
REBOUND, PUTS ON NE
I'M SURE FOR THE FLYERS CAN'T
END SOON
THE CAPITALS ON THEM.
ANOTHER SHOT, SCORE!
THE REDIRECT BY HATHAWAY.
I MEAN, THTHTE THOMPSON, AND NO
CARRIED BY BROWN, GETS THE SHOT
IT VAN RIEMSDYK IN THINK THAT G
LARSSON IS ABLE TO TAP IT HOME
THE PLAY THAT CARLSON MADE